retour demain sur les marchés des fruits
et légumes la grève de rungis est
terminée assemblée des évêques
monseigneur etchegaray il faut prendre
la crise de l'église au sérieux quarante
cinq heures d'audition par la police le
meilleur ami de ma thank you fait son
portrait mort de raymond queneau
l'auteur de zazie dans le métro
après les déclarations de georges séguy
le programme commun sera qu il réviser
le dossier du journal
bonsoir mesdames à vos cabas et à vos
filets peut être dès demain mais en tout
cas mercredi vous retrouverez des fruits
et des légumes et oui chez votre
détaillant habituel en particulier dans
la région parisienne mais tout le monde
n'était pas tout à fait partisan de la
reprise des approvisionnements loin de
là et si la situation semble
provisoirement débloqués en tout cas
pour les consommateurs le problème de
fond n'est pas réglé toujours aussi
divisée sur l'attitude à adopter face
aux propositions prix du gouvernement
les détaillants lèveront cependant tous
leurs rideaux de fer demain matin et
mercredi au plus tard seulement le
consommateur aura affaire à deux sortes
de détails
premièrement ceux qui appliqueront les
marges imposées par la direction des
prix ce sont les amis de bernard rapine
partisans de la reprise depuis jeudi
dernier
deuxièmement les détaillants qui
impliqueront des marges plus élevées
décider entre eux ce matin aux halles ce
sont les amis de lucie akharbach chef de
file de la tendance
dur de rungis tu ces derniers se mettent
hors la loi en quelque sorte et seront
probablement dans les jours qui viennent
la cible favorite des contrôleurs des
prix en invitant ses amis à reprendre
dans ces conditions lucien kerbarh
tournure échappatoire à une grève qui
s'effiloche et espère obtenir une
entrevue avec le directeur des prix
claude villain il menace en cas de refus
d'appeler de nouveau à la grève ou vous
souvenez pardon certainement de la
célèbre devise de georges marchais
petite phrase nous voulons appliquer
tout le programme commun mais rien que
le programme comme or au fur et à mesure
que s'engage un vaste débat politique à
la faveur de la sortie du livre de
valéry giscard d'estaing des différentes
déclarations de monsieur françois
mitterrand la réactualisation du
programme commun de la gauche revient au
premier plan les prochaines
consultations électorales ne sont pas
évidemment étrangères mais le grand
sujet des discussions ce sont les
nationalisations georges séguy hier soir
au club de la presse d'europe numéro un
se déclarait à première vue contre
l'avis de certains socialistes et des
radicaux de gauche mais nous y
reviendrons puisque c'est le dossier de
ce journal se déclare est donc favorable
à l'extension des nationalisations à
l'ensemble du secteur automobile et à la
sidérurgie
déclaration qui qui a une répercussion
immédiate sur la bourse de paris
une demi-heure avant la clôture ont
flâné autour de la corbeille un manque
d'animation qui traduisait le manque
d'affaires mécontente du plan barre
inquiète de ralentissement de la reprise
économique dans le monde entier
la bourse a mal accueilli l'extension du
programme commun proposé par georges cid
bref la bourse a fortement baissé
aujourd'hui
comment at il pu en être autrement alors
que nous avons appris hier soir que deux
nouveaux secteurs seraient susceptibles
de nationalisation en cas de victoire de
l'union de la gauche pour prochaines
élections législatives
le marché certes n'avait pas besoin
d'une telle nouvelle et pas donné son
état de faiblesse actuelle la science
d'aujourd'hui peut être qualifiées de
grises ou de noir comme celle qui a eu
lieu il ya quinze jours elle peut l'être
d'autant plus que vraisemblablement
aujourd'hui nous allons refranchir en
baisse le plus bas niveau atteint le 12
octobre
mais par rapport au cours de la veille
le décalage de cours est moins violent
qu'il ne l'avait été du 11 au 12 octobre
en croire la science d'aujourd'hui on
peut donc penser que la bourse crois que
la bouche emportera aux élections elle
le pense vraisemblablement aujourd'hui
puisque el pais c'est qu'elles baissent
plus particulièrement sur les secteurs
nationalisa bhl mais il
on peut également penser que d'ici
l'échéance électorale
elle sera amenée à estimer le contraire
nous parlions de la bourse à l'instant
une réponse de valéry giscard d'estaing
à un auditeur de rtl ce matin devrait
rassurer les petits épargnants et les
petits porteurs de titres
en effet d'ici à la fin de l'année a dit
le président je m'adresserai je cite
bien entendu ce qu'a dit valéry giscard
d'estaing je m'adresserai aux premiers
ministres d'une manière publique pour
lui indiquer la manière dont le
gouvernement devrait étudier un système
de mesure permettant la protection des
petits patrimoines et puis le conseil
central de planification qui définit les
grandes options économiques du
gouvernement arrêtée cet après midi mais
je la prends à l'instant trois lignes
générales d'action renforcement de la
concurrence amélioration de l'efficacité
de l'économie développement de l'emploi
et de la formation professionnelle qui
doivent réduire
je cite le communiqué l'elysée les
causes structurelles de l'inflation et
ainsi compléter les mesures qui avait
été décidée le 22 septembre par le
conseil des min
les évêques de france ont retrouvé à
lourdes reims à lourdes un certain calme
et une certaine sérénité pour poursuivre
leurs travaux après les manifestations
d'hier organisée par des chrétiens
intégristes favorable à monseigneur
lefebvre
le chef de l'épiscopat français
monseigneur etchegaray doit faire demain
matin une importante déclaration qui
sera en tout cas on le croit qui sera
consacré à la sphère lefebvre est déjà
dans un discours devant les évêques
monseigneur etchegaray a précisé les
directions dans lesquelles l'église
devait s'engager à l'occasion de cette
assemblée plénière un discours inaugural
très modéré monseigneur etchegaray
président de l'épiscopat français a
donné le ton que voudrait avoir cette
assemblée 1976 pas de polémique pas de
panique mais une prise en compte lucide
réaliste des problèmes auxquels l'église
de francs se trouvent confrontés
aujourd'hui
en premier lieu la sphère lefebvre cet
été
une secousse sismique d'antan qu'on est
bien l'épicentre est moins bien
l'amplitude a provoqué ou élargie des
crevasses qui nous invite avec prudence
la vertu de l'action disait saint thomas
d'aquin qui nous invite non certes à
changer de route mais à nous arrêter un
instant juste le temps de mieux voir
pourquoi ça ne suis pas autant qu'on le
souhaitait ou qu'il le faudrait autre
thème de réflexion la messe centre de la
vie des croyants elle doit manifester
leur unité et leur cohésion
le christ a confié à son église le don
de son corps et de son sang il nous
appartient d'accueillir et de respecter
fidèlement le rite de la messe tels que
le pape paul si cela produit des appels
à l'unité à la communion avec le pape à
lourdes l'assemblée 1976 ne se battra
pas contre monseigneur lefebvre mais
résolument pour l'église du concile et
de paul 6 finalement rien n'est jamais
tout à fait inutile même le bruit même
les outrances même les excès en réalité
ce qu'on a appelé le schisme de
monseigneur marcel lefebvre et dont on
ne sait pas très bien ce que c'est
maintenant s'est révélé être en tout cas
un fantastique signal d'alarmé pour
l'église de france et pour les listes
cours si tant est que l'on puisse
employer ce terme pour le peuple de dieu
que certains appellent le peuple de
france elle-même c'est-à-dire tout le
monde
l'église le mot peut dire deux choses
bien précises pour les uns il s'agit de
la fois sentiments profonds enrichissant
lignes directrices d'une façon de vivre
et d'une façon d'être
pour les autres les noms et majorité
l'église cela veut dire une pratique
oublier des notions confuse des
souvenirs de cierges de confession de
dentelle blanche de bons repas mais pour
cette foule de gens dont beaucoup ont
parfois oublié le mot catholique à la
mention religion pour cette foule de
gens l'église c'est aussi la
représentation concrète d'une simple
morale sociale sa présence son existence
le rappel permanent de ce qui se fait et
de ce qui ne se fait pas je sais que
pour certains jeux board ainsi
hérésie pour ceux qui armés de leur foi
profonde conscient de ce que l'église
peut donner ou du moins laissé choisir à
notre société veut aller vite changer la
forme pour mieux redécouvrir le font les
élèves de france se sont sans doute
aperçu que derrière ces bélier fougueuse
se traînait un troupeau lassé de marché
trop vite déjà certaines brebis regrette
d'être de sortie de l'établé pour gagner
alpages et les pasteurs vont sans doute
demain s'arrêter un moment le temps peut
être de repérer les toiles qui guide le
chemin difficile très difficile
l'enquète à grenoble sur la sphère des
brigades rouges jusqu'à présent la
police n'a obtenu de joël may tensio le
meurtrier présumé
aucun aveu à notre connaissance en tout
cas aucun indice sur les circonstances
des différents rapts et des assassinats
les enquêteurs attendent le verdict des
experts sur les pièces à conviction pour
se prononcer notamment en ce qui
concerne les machines à écrire et larmes
des cris
jusqu'à présent même le meilleur ami de
matane sio francis qui étaient entendus
qui a été entendu pendant quarante cinq
heures par les policiers et qui est émis
tout à fait hors de cause n'a fait avant
celle enquête mais francis miglia zoo
reste pour le moment un témoin capital
dans son appartement de saint martin
d'hères aux côtés de sa femme franck
aille de sa petite fille francis essaie
d'oublier le cauchemar qu'ils ont vécu
pendant quarante cinq heures cela parce
que matencio leurs amis a faussement
accusé francis d'être le propriétaire de
larmes de petit calibre trouvait à son
domicile et dont les policiers pensent
qu'elle a peut-être été utilisé lors de
l'enlèvement de muriel trajet l'cie et
de christian leroy francis nous a dit
comment cette arme s'étaient retrouvés
chez lui
bonjour j'ai acheté une carabine dans un
endroit
lui et moi on a essayé d'aller tirer lui
m'a dit je connais un endroit où on ne
tirait la vie avec lui c'était là la
fameuse décharge publique de
la sellerie âge voilà c'est lui qui
nomme les noms de là bas il m'a dit bon
avant ça j'ai quelques changements vers
par là s'y cacher on va le chercher
non je suis alors je me suis vue là je
peux te disent n'être et sur les pierres
il y avait un univers où la donne et
vous lui en voulez apprendre à joël bien
entendu jamais voir ni comme danseur
dans le pétrin dans lequel mami est ce
que vous étiez au courant des ennuis
qu'il a eu déjà précédemment c'est à
dire dans la sphère marina flèche il a
quand même fait de la fusion plusieurs
fois oui j'étais au courant mais à moi
il m'avait dit qu'il avait été établi
qu'il allait la grèce qui s'était
terminée et quelles étaient vos rapports
avec les deux liens d'amitié comme ça
c'est un garçon sympa très simple et
très gentille serviable
c'est pas qu'on rigolait bien et des
choses très désagréable qui a été dit et
écrit sur vous qu'est ce que vous en
pensez tout ça j'en pense que quand même
un vendeur de dire toutes les choses que
l'on dit sur moi j'aurais dû faire une
enquête venir chez moi interrogé les
gens qui viennent trouvera sur une
parvenu vers ma famille que j'ai vu que
j'ai vécu un moment avec lui puis ça
veut se prouver que ma femme quand même
et elle a été chez moi il ya des jeunes
qui a quand même travaillé en qui je
travaille entre temps complet
nouveau meeting monstre à pékin avec
pour la première fois hier après-midi
l'apparition en public du successeur de
marc ou le chihuahua fang de nouveaux
dirigeants chinois avaient revêtu à
cette occasion la tenue verte de l'armée
populaire
on ne connaît toujours pas la
composition de la nouvelle équipe
un journal de pékin a simplement
souligné ce matin que la nomination de
monsieur bako fang a été décidée par mao
lui même en avril dernier par le même
journal on apprend que les quatre
traître dont la veuve de mao seront
rééduquer ouverture cet après midi au
caire du huitième sommet arabe le
président sadate accueille les rois et
chefs d'état qui doivent consolider le
cessez-le-feu au liban cette réunion a
pour but d'entériner les décisions
prises à riyad en arabie saoudite et qui
permettront de rétablir la paix dans ce
pays où la guerre civile dure depuis 18
mois
l'une des décisions importantes qui doit
être prise la nationalité des trente
mille soldats qui s'interposeront entre
les belligérants des casques verts
seront sous l'autorité du président de
la république libanaise
monsieur sartis
lundi noir à la bourse de londres la
livre sterling vient de perdre plus de 4
pour cent de sa valeur par rapport aux
autres monnaies les achats de la banque
d'angleterre n'ont pas réussi à freiner
cette chute à l'origine de cet
effondrement une rumeur lancée hier par
le sunday times les états unis et le
fonds monétaire international aurait
refusé un nouveau prêt au gouvernement
britannique depuis mars dernier la livre
sterling s'est dévaluée de 22% par
rapport au dollar
jacques fouroux numéro 9 tricot blanc et
culotte bleue joué hier soir à bordeaux
en rugby à 15 comme capitaine de
l'équipe de france dans cette rencontre
qui opposait la france aux australiens
fouroux a fait une partie que l'on a
qualifié d' assez médiocre les
sélectionneurs ont donc décidé de le
remplacer par le biterrois richard
as tu as qui n'est pourtant pas en
grande forme actuellement devra assurer
la direction de l'équipe pour le
deuxième match qui aura lieu samedi
prochain au parc des princes contre les
australiens james hunt champion du monde
des conducteurs de formule 1
bravo bravo sans restriction mais
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas de lui que l'on
parle c'est de nikki niki lauda battu
d'un point après avoir abandonné au 1er
tour du grand prix du japon
lauda a eu peur lauda s'est dégonflé
passez moi l'expression c'est ce que
l'on entend en tout cas dans les
commentaires le public vous le savez
bien les pas tendre pour le vaincu même
s'il se remet tout juste d'un terrible
accident
alors peut-être peut-on tout de même
trouvé au champion autrichien au moins
quelques raisons sinon quelques excuses
un pilote professionnel doit se battre
jusqu'au bout il n'a pas le droit de
renoncer
surtout quand le titre de champion du
monde est en jeu tels ont été les
commentaires des adversaires de niki
lauda après son abandon au grand prix du
japon
aucune circonstance atténuante
le lui a été accordé
en quelques minutes d'exemples de
référence l'autrichien devenu un paria
condamné par ses homologues dans le
milieu de la compétition automobile tout
le monde a peur mais il n'est pas
question de l'avouer et pourtant le
déroulement du grand prix a donné raison
à lauda vous pouvez le constater
tellement et risque à prendre était
énorme
les bolides de formule 1 tant qu ils
sont à conduisible et les pilotes jouent
au casque ou pire au trompe la mort il
est donc compréhensible que lauda
convalescent retrouvant les conditions
de son accident ait préféré renoncer
cette décision ne concerne que moi mais
j'estime qu'il était impossible de
courir les autres font ce qu'ils veulent
ça ne me regarde pas le père de zazi
résident le métro vous connaissez
certainement est mort ce matin à paris à
l'âge de 73 ans poète et romancier
raymond queneau n'était peut-être pas
assez connu du public sa poésie et son
humour son oeuvre tout entier retient
pourtant une grande place dans notre
littérature par sa diversité aussi par
sa densité vraiment que l'on a écrit
lui-même sa biographie il l'a même
écrite en verre des verts tout simple
vous allez voir jeunes acquise au havre
21 février en 1900 et 3 ma mère était
mercier raymond père mercier il
trépignait de joie inexplicablement jeu
connu la justice et fut mise à matin
chez une femme à vis des bêtes une
nourrice qui me tendit son sein etc etc
voilà le style de queneau quand il se
moquait de lui même
il avait tellement le goût de l'humour
qu'il était inévitable que son nom soit
lié à la chanson juliette gréco a chanté
si tu t'imagines les frères jacques ont
interprété les exercices de style que
l'eau c'est l'homme qui démantibulé
l'orthographe qui écrivait qu'est que
c'est que ça avec des cadets x c'est
l'homme qui dans les exercices de style
écrivait 99 variations pas une de moins
sur l'anecdote la plus quelconques une
querelle dans un autobus en la racontant
successivement en argot sur le ton de la
femme du monde du monsieur décor et
réactionnaire etc
il ya une quinzaine d'années et oui déjà
il m'avait expliqué la naissance de ce
merveilleux canular
c'est au cours d'un concert no jouer du
bach que j'ai pensé que l'on pouvait
faire l'équivalent dans le domaine
littéraire et prendre un thème elle
prêtait de multiples façons d un thème
particulièrement simple pour que les
différentes façons soit mieux
perceptible et finalement j'ai pris un
thème tout à fait insignifiant
il y en a qui sont basées sur des
figures de rhétorique
ah oui non et puis il y en a un où notre
ensemble qu'ils semblent les variations
de langage largo le français prononcer
avec l'accent italien l'accent anglais
ou bien france fait tout pour aider les
niches dont vous êtes amusé à les écrire
je crois est-ce que cet exercice drôle
dont pour vous comme pour nous et en
même temps important est ce qu'il vous a
apporté quelque chose en ce qui concerne
l'étude du style ou peut-être même du
langage
ce soit peut-être un intérêt c'était
tout que nous cela un rire une dérobade
seulement voilà quelle générosité sous
la grimace et puis quel écrivain
les nationalisations sont donc à nouveau
à l'ordre du jour avec les déclarations
de georges séguy hier soir et les très
nombreux commentaires et réactions qui
leur ont fait suite
aujourd'hui georges georges séguy
souhaite dans l'hypothèse de
l'application du programme commun de
nouvelles nationalisations ajoutée aux
neuf déjà prêt l'ensemble du secteur de
l'automobile et de la cire et ronchi
sidérurgique pardon mais nationaliser
cela sert à quoi au fond c'est peut-être
la première question que l'on peut se
poser en ouvrant ce dossier nationaliser
ces transférer certains biens privés de
production à la nation l'état assurant
la responsabilité la propriété et gérant
l'entreprise aujourd'hui les entreprises
publiques sont concentrés dans cinq
grands secteurs l'énergie les transports
les industries mécanique la chimie et
les banques et elles sont nées de deux
grande vague de nationalisations en 1936
et 1940 si dans l'ensemble ces
nationalisations obéit autant à une
logique économique qu'à des contingences
historiques lorsque le front populaire
décide de nationaliser dix entreprises
privées aéronautique
il entend surtout faire face à la montée
inquiétante de l'hitlérisme mettez pour
des raisons économiques qu'à la même
époque
les compagnies ferroviaires toutes
déficitaires vont fusionner pour donner
naissance à la sncf en 1946 les
nécessités la reconstruction tout l'état
à mettre tout son contrôle les grands
secteurs de base de lait connu d'où la
nationalisation des houillères du nord
pas de calais des charbonnages de france
de l'edf gdf de la banque de france et
d'air france mais c'est pour des raisons
de sanctions à cause de leur
collaboration avec les allemands que
renault sera nationalisé ainsi que l'
agence havas qui deviendra par la suite
l' agence france-presse
le programme commun né en 1972 propose
neuf nationalisations d'entreprises
privées qui sont cités nommément
ce sont dassault ou celle du claf qui
depuis est passé sous contrôle
majoritaire allemand rhône poulenc
il était france thomson brandt honeywell
bull pechiney ugine kuhlmann saint
gobain pont à mousson et la compagnie
générale d'électricité et le programme
commun précise que toutes les
entreprises ne voient pas
être nationalisées et qu'un important
secteur privé devra subsister si
nationaliser la sidérurgie ne pose dans
l'absolu aucun problème en revanche pour
l'automobile c'est différent puisque
certaines firmes comme simca chrysler
sont maintenant étrangères mais dans
l'esprit de georges séguy les modalités
de ces nationalisations ne sont pas
arrêtés ce qui compte c'est la volonté
la volonté syndicats le voir politique
de le faire et comme vous allez le
entendre de la part de l'un des
dirigeants de la centrale syndicale
pourquoi s'étonner d'une telle prise de
position la cgt a toujours été pour une
certaine réactualisation du programme
commun en tout cas une certaine
adaptation au terrain franco georges
séguy a nommé citroën il voulait nommer
le groupe citroën peugeot
quant à chrysler ce n'est pas un
problème d'une importance capitale pour
l'économie mais ce n'est qu'une faible
part du marché français mais il faut
reconnaître que comme organisations
syndicales nous avons des raisons
particulières nous y intéresser parce
que c'est une entreprise où la
répression antisyndicale un caractère
particulièrement scandaleux illégale et
même avec l'emploi de procéder fascistes
mais encore une fois la cgt à une
certaine appréciation de ces choses
elle soutient le programme commun des
partis gauche et c'est aux partis de
gauche de décider de ce que doit être le
contenu exact ce programme
l'automobile française c'est-à-dire
peugeot citroën et cynthia crise claires
- renault déjà nationalisé a représenté
en 1975 une production totale d'un peu
moins de 2 millions de véhicules un peu
plus de 33 milliards de francs de
chiffre d'affaires hors taxe et employés
165 mille personnes après le bâtiment et
les travaux publics l'automobile et le
secteur industriel le plus important en
france de par son poids spécifique dans
l'économie mais aussi en raison des
nombreux sous traitants qui en vit
j'aimerais préciser à point puisqu'il a
été dit
une autre société française automobile
et nous-mêmes recevions des fonds
importants de l'état français j'aimerais
précise en ce qui nous concerne nous
n'avons pas reçu de fonds nous ne
recevons pas de fonds et d'autre part
nous avons le sentiment d'être une
société française jouant une part active
dans l'économie française puisque nous
employons un peu plus de 40000 personnes
n'est qu'en 75 et sur la cinquième
société spectatrice françaises veulent
une unité française mais votre principal
actionnaire et amériques
notre principal actionnaire et
américains nous faisons partie d'un
groupe multinational
mais comme je vous le signale quand on
emploie quarante mille personnes et même
plus en france on pèse un certain poids
dans l'industrie française et on peut se
considérer comme français
et puis la sidérurgie en 1975 a produit
21 million et demi de tonnes d'acier
réalisé un chiffre d'affaires de 28
milliards et demi de francs hors taxes
et employés cent cinquante cinq mille
cinq cents personnes
compte tenu des investissements très
lourds est nécessaire la sidérurgie
française est un secteur très endettés
en 1975
l'endettement global de la sidérurgie
étaient équivalents à son chiffre
d'affaires hors taxes c'est à dire 28
milliard et demi de francs dont 20 % de
prêts publics comme le soulignait
aujourd'hui claude estier scrutin
national du parti socialiste il y a
longtemps que georges marchais a évoqué
la nationalisation de la sidérurgie et
françois mitterrand celle de
l'automobile
mais ni l'une ni l'autre ne sont dans le
programme comme françois mitterrand dans
paris-match souhaité hier dans paris
match qui paraît aujourd'hui s'en tenir
strictement au contenu actuel du
programme commun alors que claude estier
envisage comme tout à fait possible
l'ouverture d'une discussion sur les
propositions de georges sig
autrement dit une discussion sera
absolument nécessaire car si les
socialistes restent prudents les
radicaux de gauche sont plutôt hostiles
et les communistes vous allez l'entendre
plutôt favorable en ce qui concerne la
nationalisation de la sidérurgie et
celle de la compagnie française des
pétroles le programme commun prévoit une
prise de participation pouvant être
majoritaire nous avons proposé que la
nationalisation de ces sociétés soit
complète
en ce qui concerne citroën c'est à dire
aujourd'hui
ou peugeot citroën compte tenu de la
masse de fonds publics qui sont investis
dans cette affaire privée
depuis la fin de 1974 nous proposons la
nationalisation de ce groupe et nous
l'avons fait dès la fin 74 ces positions
sont toutes connues et et nous nous y
tenons
il faut donner toute la portée aux
propositions du prg en commun en matière
de nationalisation comme en matière
d'objectifs sociaux ou politiques
financières la position des radicaux de
gauche est extrêmement réservé sur les
nationalisations
il considère que c'est un procédé très
très onéreux de contrôle de l'économie
et qu'il en existe qui sont beaucoup
moins onéreux que les nationalisations
risque de conduire des étatisation ce
que nous ne voulons pas et en tout cas à
la création d'entreprise gigantesque
c'est à dire qu'ils ne soient plus les
entreprise à dimension humaine alors que
nous pensons qu'au contraire le problème
est à l'époque contemporaine d'empêcher
le gigantisme des entreprises alors
selon vous il n'est pas nécessaire de
modifier le programme commun où il est
nécessaire de le modifier dans votre
sens et je ne pense pas qu'il soit
raisonnable actuellement de dire en 1978
voilà ce que l'économie française pourra
faire dans le domaine des
nationalisations vie doit être très
clair que si par impossible négociations
étaient ouvertes sur ce plan là
la violence des radicaux de gauche s'ils
avaient une influence dans cette
négociation et ils voudront l'avoir ne
s'exercera pas pour influer le contenu
des nationalisations mais tout au
contraire pour le réduire
embarrassé chacun des partis de gauche
françois mitterrand ici en 1972 s'est
efforcé de répondre aux affirmations de
georges séguy mais cet embarras signifie
surtout que les discussions sur ce sujet
ne sont pas closes aujourd'hui à gauche
tous s'étonnent de l'étonnement général
car il n'y a officiellement rien de neuf
voilà nous refermons tout à fait
provisoirement ce dossier car bien
entendu le débat sur les
nationalisations ne fait que commencer
un mot du temps et rapidement pour
terminer ce journal aujourd'hui à
l'exception du sud ouest de l'est les
températures étaient en hausse mais il a
encore plus sur une bonne partie de la
france demain après des brumes matinales
le temps sera très nuageux à couvert
avec encore de la pluie sur une bonne
partie de la france des orages dans le
millier sur les massifs montagneux de la
neige en altitude et des vents assez
forts en méditerranée
avec toute la rédaction d'antenne 2 je
vous remercie d'avoir suivi l'édition de
ce journal bonsoir et tout de suite le
rappel des principaux titres de
l'actualité
araji cela grève des fruits et légumes
été remis aux brigades rouges les
policiers attendent les résultats des
experts l'auteur de zazie dans le métro
est mort un débat s'est engagé à gauche
après les propositions de georges séguy
le dernier journal d'antenne 2 23h30